but we begin this morning with rising
tensions in Washington over the release
of the Muller report Attorney General
William Barr announced Friday it will be
made public within two weeks though
Democrats are demanding it be sent to
them sooner
even though bars for page summary found
no evidence of collusion House Judiciary
Chairman Jerrold Nadler is calling on
Barr to honor his deadline of sharing
the four hundred page document by
Tuesday the push comes with questions
about the contents of the report and
just how much of the report will be
redacted it's one reason why Democrats
have locked in dates for bar to testify
about the findings on Capitol Hill
president Trump is spending the weekend
at mar-a-lago Mull Alinghi is in West
Palm Beach and is traveling with the
president mola good morning Anthony
Michelle good morning president Trump
has accepted the Attorney General's
commitment in a letter to Congress to
release the Mullah report by mid-april
and to testify before Congress in early
May after a week of Democrats demanding
the Attorney General released the full
mulher report AG William Bar has agreed
to send Congress a redacted version by
mid-april if that's what I'd like to do
I have nothing to hide
this was a hoax this was a witch-hunt
upon the conclusion of the special
counsels investigation last week Barr
sent Congress a four-page summary of
Muller's nearly four hundred page report
noting that neither the president nor
his presidential campaign associates
colluded with the Russians during the
2016 election but the report did not
exonerate mr. Trump of obstructing
justice House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
tweeted Friday the American people
deserved the facts not a watered-down
interpretation President Trump spent the
week declaring victory and vindication
and slander the Russia hoax is finally
dead
the collusion delusion is over the
president has not seen the report and it
will not be shared with the White House
in advance of its release Attorney
General Barr says he is available to
testify before the Senate Judiciary
Committee on May 1st and before the
House Judiciary Committee on May 2nd
should be an active few days on the hill
Tony active indeed mullah thank you very
much